why don't we go next to Smith from
Phoenix Smith from Phoenix welcome to
the program uh please unmute yourself
what's on your mind today
hello uh so with uh Rhonda Santos
seemingly joining in the race later
today officially and he's doing it with
Fanfare with Elon Musk
uh
I've been thinking about why Elon is
wanting to do this with DeSantis and
what I'm thinking and let me know what
you think about this Elon wants to do
this to basic
Glee incentivize Trump to come back on
news platform and basically have a
Twitter war between the Santos and Trump
on his platform I'm not entirely
convinced Elon is doing this to say he's
endorsing the sandus but to bring him on
his platform to
and essentially Cokes Trump back on the
platform when he hasn't so far
surprisingly yeah I don't think you're
wrong about that being a possible
motivation for musk I think there are
others as well including that he's
seeing this as a way to potentially be a
bigger player in the presidential
campaign and uh you know there's there's
personal ego reasons and different
things but this this is something a
couple people actually emailed me about
Smith which was the idea that this is
going to make this is if Trump does
nothing as far as Twitter goes this will
make Twitter even more of a pro de Santa
Safe Haven it'll make it overtly one and
Twitter has become very right-wing since
Elon Musk took it over you look at the
for you feed and it's just right-wing
nonsense so I think that Elon Musk May
indeed be making the calculation you're
making which is maybe this is how you
get Trump back on Twitter and Twitter
becomes the platform where this uh
Republican primary plays out which is
just great for Twitter which quite
frankly does doesn't seem to be doing
that well right now
yeah
I agree with that uh
to the to me Elon is under the guise of
free speeches really coaxing on
Republicans I'm not sure how that's
going to work for him long uh in the
long term but yeah I don't either you
know a lot of these the scientists
people don't like electric vehicles and
they don't like a lot of what Elon Musk
is up to and when you actually think
about it so I don't know you know
politics makes strange bedfellows but
let's give it a few weeks and then we'll
analyze it
all right Smith from Phoenix thank you
so much for the call appreciate it thank
you very much let's take a very quick
break and then we'll come back and hear
from some more folks so if you're
waiting to talk to me uh just hang on